ah nature hi I'm Garrett and I'm Nikki
we're fascinated by how other people
live so we're gonna try and find some
really interesting living situations and
live they're experiencing a totally
different lifestyle to see what tones
will bring us closer together or push us
further apart
this week we're living on our ranch this
is what ranches look like it's thousands
of acres huge I'm gene I'm Eric and
we're here at the cold Creek Ranch and
we've been on this ranch for 12 years
the idea here is to apply everything we
know to manage land or its best health
not for the cattles health for the
land's health and then the cattles
health will follow lifestyle on a ranch
to me sounds like you're wearing cowboy
boots and you're using those cowboy
boots to step in horse [ __ ] all day long
I've never lived in any sort of ranch or
farm or wild countryside in the wild
wild west
wild where our own water company our own
Electric Company only one part of the
ranch has real electricity a typical day
you could start out shoeing a horse and
because of something happening in two
hours later you might be repairing a
water line it's all over the place all
the time all I know about ranches is
what I've seen on TV and movies not a
great frame of reference I feel like I'm
gonna meet a farmhand and fall in love
with him while he carries hay bales and
I sit inside drinking tea and like a
ridiculous pink dress a lot of people
get excited about ranches I don't get it
I won't think horses are cool I don't
think cows are cool I don't like the
idea of ranches I like barbecue
it's beautiful doors that horse foot
knock yes yeah use it Nikki and I we
live in a lot of different places at all
feel like the 21st century this feels
like it's from the late 1800s
the only heat we've got oh my goodness I
only have to heat this house about three
weeks out of the year the rest the
tighter trying to cool it off yeah I
live my entire life in cities this is
gonna be a very very different lifestyle
I'm pretty scared this is the living
room although there's got to be a better
name for Tibet we're turning it into a
library the woodwork is all made by
local joiners who really know their
craft it's hard to join something that's
not straight I'll show you the way
upstairs the Western room in the Africa
room you guys can choose flip a coin
whatever you want to do decide who gets
which room do they join yes yes they do
oh it's a shared bathroom on YouTube
this is perfect so this is the Africa
room Wow we have spent a lot of time in
Africa to be honest nothing freaks me
out a little bit I mean it's very
beautiful but the eyeballs so you can
know this room that's fine I think this
is gonna require a lot of like early
mornings and labor I am probably gonna
look like a real stupid city kid I'm not
gonna know how anything works I'm really
nervous about this ranch hopefully we
can rely on each other instead of
feeling burdened by one another I don't
think it will bode well for our
relationship well we're gonna head on up
the telephone trailer this is something
I do usually once a day because there is
no cell phone coverage a bottomless
canyon so many people now think of the
landscape is just sort of a backdrop it
has nothing to do with anything they do
in their lives and they come away from
here generally with a very very vivid
idea of just how involved we are with
our landscape it's a lifestyle it's not
a career in that sense it blew my mind
that you could own all the land to
basically the horizon we got to see as
much of the property as we could from
one vantage point which is crazy because
that's something like 10,000 acres you
only have to conserve electricity at
night for like six weeks out of the year
and we just happen to be here during one
of those weeks we cooked dinner in the
dark which is a little scary because I
was working with knives but still have
all my fingers tomorrow should be a full
day of work and it's really like
whatever the ranch needs taking care of
tomorrow is whatever we will tend to
let's go say good
did you hear okay good night Nikki
sleep tight I'm just gonna be in there
with my door open so the heat okay it's
about 7:00 a sham and I think it's
raining so I don't know what that means
for today but we might have to change
your plans thank you for breakfast
there's solar panels they're not gonna
get much electricity today we've made
some alternative arrangements depending
on up to learning how to shoot a horse
you are how many horses you see you got
up here there's four in here now but we
got three more up on top and then a
whole bunch of strays over on another
side of the ranch get out of here
leave me alone it's taller than the
horse I'm gonna feed you we had to
switch to plan B which involved taking
care of the horses that was kind of an
opportunity that Eric and gene had to do
tasks that they don't usually have time
to do she didn't choose me this is sugar
right here the deep red woman
you said pretty sure needs some new pair
of shoes
one two pairs two pairs of shoes so one
of the main purposes of trimming horses
feet is to make sure that finger nail is
trimmed back so it doesn't interfere
with the proper movement I push the Tang
away from me and use only the coarse
side pulling is easier than pushing and
go around like that into your shape and
you'll see there's a white line here you
don't want to go any closer in than that
that's how we're gonna do it
[Music]
unrest on the sugar for a little while
now it's tough working with this
gigantic animal that could kill you if
you want it come on doesn't even know
what's good for it this would be so much
nicer come on it's cold I can't feel my
hands not here for like an hour I think
and we've done two of sugars feet like a
pedicure no let me confess something
that may not be that surprising these
are my first time putting on chaps
well your first problem is pronouncing
it correctly chef's not chap chefs chaps
or British dudes this is to protect us
from Horseman's yes in this case yeah
and you who Garrett and I have just been
working all day
but we've been working together I think
you know we're enjoying each other's
company good we were doing things way
outside our comfort zone so it's really
nice to have a friend check in on me to
make sure I was good I look great like a
million bucks
all right fine all right put your ship
for two sure yeah
so the trick is to drive the nail in
such a way that goes through gets a good
chunk of the hoof without cutting into
the quick still enough coming out the
other side the chicken hands for this oh
my hands this is tough stuff and I feel
like a total weenie but it's rewarding I
guess like this is part of taking care
of your horses how you doing another one
Eric said when he came out to this land
who'd shoot eight horses a day of filing
and nailing it in and oh my god it's a
lot of work you got a nikkie keep at it
I'm half covered in poop
I can't believe we did so little in four
hours we gave her two shoes because we
were taking too long and she was getting
fussy my hands are so tired I can't even
hold a hammer anymore if I swing a
hammer is gonna fly out of my hand if I
do this by myself I don't know what we
do I guess I'd shoot a horse with one
shoe a day after lunch we oiled saddles
that sucked we are going to be doing
annual maintenance on our working stock
saddle should I take off my cute socks
yeah well you can actually use your cute
socks to oil with oh we go change my
socks you just go ahead and put some oil
on the sponge and just sponge it in okay
how do you know you've done enough well
the oil soaks right in but you can see
the difference so far it's just a lot I
work with your hands huh good yeah
manual labor there's like a latitude
here I guess I'm more used to like a
precision for everything you have to do
but here there's really a latitude of
like yeah that's fine yeah that's fine
which is what you need to survive out
here it is a hard life out here and now
I totally get it when Eric says it
doesn't matter what day it is they do
what they have to do and they do what
the ranch demands then like what
well ours I think we're done I'm done
here so we're done carrots not done just
a lot of work yep
a lot of work a lot of work just to be
able to work my body's sore when I was
sitting there oiling the saddles I kind
of noticed my leg was hurting and I
found like a gnarly bruise here's the
bruising it's kind of blue today was
just like a grueling day and it wasn't
even like his grilling as it could have
been because of the rain you still have
another early morning ahead of us
tomorrow maybe the cows if the weather
permits it we're not done yet no thanks
hmm it's the morning of day 3 um it
doesn't look like it's raining so let's
go see some house what we'd like to do
is show the cows that we have some
additional supplement form right now
like a like a heavy med ball you know
well you get your exercise that's what I
can guarantee yeah how many cows do we
need to lure in order for this to be
successful oh we've got 50 last time
you're looking at probably 30 right now
I don't see any cows
yes oh okay and then I say third one
there okay so that's free
literally hey cows yep now just do like
this to kind of broadcast
[Laughter]
that was good you should try Garrett
[Music]
it's like Chewbacca hollow needles how
they come around like ah this is the
other lesson you get from ranching his
patients yeah those in that one
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been only half an hour 45 minutes
of calling cows out here and we think
it's too cold and they've kind of
settled in for the day yeah good job
though you gotta move in yeah I'm
starting yeah we got some progress made
but not a whole lot thank you guys oh my
god this is one of the most difficult
living experiences I've ever had it took
so long to get out to where the cows are
and so hard and you've just got to be
doing it for the good of the cows for
the good of the land and to survive gene
and Eric took care of us very very well
but taking part in a tiny part of their
lives has exhausted me it's physically
challenging but it's also mentally
challenging I thought it was going to be
Nikki and I barely hanging on and kind
of looking to each other for sort of
strength but Nikki was so strong shoeing
the horses and calling the cattle and
doing everything there's no time for
Garrett night to be annoyed with each
other or to piss each other off
we were shoeing a horse and when he
couldn't do it anymore I had to step in
and do it and when I couldn't do it
anymore he would step back in and do it
at the end of the day we were just there
for each other this landscape can get
really lonely so it was great to have
her there
it's only been three days I'm I feel
like my body's falling apart it's so
hard to live out here and I have so much
respect for the people who do it next
week on homebodies earthships it sounds
a little highfalutin and hippie-dippy
is a garage with like plants in it I
think they grow their own vegetables fat
scale your birds there's birds there's
birds this is fascinating we're doing a
pretty bad job but we're learning
you